hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich zeige euch heute ganz kurz wie
man eine runde torte mit von dor
eindecken kann von dort eine zuckerpaste
die ausgerollt wird und dann über torten
gelegt wird grundsätzlich müsst ihr dann
mit dabei beachten dass ihr eine
geeignete unterlagen findet eine
geeignete creme die darf nämlich nicht
zu feucht sein da ansonsten sich davon
doch mit dieser feuchtigkeit versorgt
und dann sich auflöst deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier bereits eine torte
vorbereitet und habt ihr mit gage
eingestrichen
alternativ könnten zum beispiel aber
auch eine amerikanische buttercreme
nehmen
die bestehen nämlich nur aus fett und
aus zucker die torte ist jetzt bereit
die das jetzt hier an der seite und
nehme jetzt den von dort muss dann
erfuhr weich kneten
am besten lässt sich von dort mit etwas
kokosfett weich kneten das nimmt ihr
einfach in die hände und verteilt ist
gut und dann kann man schön weiß kneten
von da lässt sich am besten auch etwas
becker stärker ausrollen und dann
versuche ich es eben so einfach 3 bis 4
mm dünn auszuholen
den von der rolle ich dann auf den aus
rolf starb auf und kann die pforte hier
platzieren
und weil die oberfläche jetzt trocken
hier sind wir von dort nicht gut haften
würde besprüht sie jetzt mit etwas
wachstumsfeld alternativ wird auch ein
bisschen wasser gehen
und jetzt kann man den davon doch
einfach drüber legen
jetzt wird zuerst die oberfläche
geklettert und die luft drückt man somit
nach außen und dann muss man hier am
rand immer wieder denn von dort
wegziehen und mit der anderen hand glatt
streichen
die groben reste schneide ich dann
erstmal mit einem marzipan messer weg
und den rest kann man immer ganz gut
aufbewahren luftdicht verpacken und kann
ihn das nächste mal weiter benutzt und
dann setze ich das messer noch mal an
ganz dicht an der torte und schneidet
direkt am rand den überrest rick
jetzt kann die torte an der oberfläche
und an den seiten mit zwei freunden
damit klettern und geglättet werden
und wenn jetzt noch ganz scharfe kanten
hier außen haben möchte kann man noch
diesen kanten form annehmen und den hier
ansetzen und glatt streichen
alternativ geht es aber auch mit diesen
zwei von und klettern da muss man den
einen hier ansetzen und mit dem anderen
hier im richtungen typewriter drücken
die torte sitzt glatt gestrichen und sie
kann jetzt so entweder weiter verwendet
werden oder weiter dekoriert werden die
von torten dürfen natürlich auch im
kühlschrank gelagert werden die
oberfläche trocknet dann so ein bisschen
an
und dann kann da auch wirklich nichts
mehr passieren ich hoffe dass ich euch
mit diesem video helfen konnte und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim torten
eindecken bis zum nächsten mal